bílek de mí eres una mujer especial de 7
es la única mutar jefa de barrio en la
provincia de diyarbakir el extra de
turquía y una de las regiones más
conservadoras del país su principal
labor ha sido luchar contra los
matrimonios forzados e infantiles
[Aplausos]
[Música]
soy como la madre del barrio los vecinos
me ven como si fuese una hermana mayor
no me comporto como una mujer sino como
alguien de la familia y ellos me ven a
sí o no al baile le ríen mejor y lucha
su camino hasta aquí sin embargo no fue
fácil a los 14 años el padre de demi le
obligó a casarse con un extraño con
quien tuvo cuatro hijos al final logró
divorciarse
mi vida como casada se convirtió en una
pesadilla una pesadilla de principio a
fin abusos sexuales a una menor como era
yo a esta edad legalmente uno no se
puede casar hasta los 18 años se
considera que eres un niño comencé a
sufrir cada día como una pesadilla
de mir decidió presentarse a mutar para
evitar que más niñas ofrecen lo que ella
vivió según datos de varias
organizaciones el 15 por ciento de las
jóvenes turcas se casan antes de los 18
años y casi todas lo hacen forzosamente
según los expertos en acción también en
este marcador en esa onda que anuncia es
una denuncia
en esta región casi todos somos incluido
yo gente cuyas madres se han casado con
13 o 14 años si no cambiamos la
percepción de que las niñas son objetos
si seguimos como ahora no habrá forma de
solucionar esta problemática
antonio durante los últimos años está
jefa de barrio ha conseguido que 40
niñas de la ciudad no sean casadas a la
fuerza
queremos darle la mano a las niñas y a
los jóvenes porque son el futuro no
podemos permitir que una chica abandone
la escuela porque es forzada a casarse
una sociedad que no tiene infancia es
una sociedad bajo ya ha sido un trayecto
largo y lleno de insultos y amenazas
pero él no se deja intimidar en un país
donde los matrimonios infantiles son aún
comunes esta mujer todavía tiene mucho
trabajo por hacer